so in this video I want to talk about
why diabetics should always use apple
cider vinegar especially diabetics ok or
anyone with blood sugar issues or
insulin resistance so what is outside of
vinegar basically you're taking apple
juice you're fermenting it with a
certain yeast to alcohol or ethanol then
the bacteria called acetic acid bacteria
takes it one step further and makes
vinegar or acetic acid and if the acetic
acid that inhibits insulin it makes
insulin more sensitive now some of you
watching are diabetic type one okay and
you don't make enough insulin this is
still good for you because it'll make
insulin more sensitive if you're type
one chances are you also have insulin
resistance so really acetic acid
improves insulin resistance type two
diabetes is a situation where you have
high amounts of blood sugar because the
insulin is not working you have insulin
resistance but the body compensates by
making more insulin so if you have a
situation we have too much insulin but
it's ineffective that's why they call it
insulin resistance acetic acid from the
vinegar will basically help this
situation and help lower your blood
Sugar's so I would recommend two
tablespoons and at least eight ounces of
water maybe twelve ounces would be even
better before bed use a straw because
you don't want the acid on your teeth I
would also recommend consuming it with
meals what you're going to find is your
blood sugars are going to come down now
when you do this simple remedy to help
your blood Sugar's you want to test your
blood Sugar's okay it's gonna happen
your blood sugars are going to come down
to normal and sometimes below normal
into a hypoglycemic state in which case
you need to adjust your medication
because you never want to take blood
pressure medication if your blood sugars
are normal or too low because it's gonna
make it even lower check with your
doctor on that one point but it'll
probably happen gradually and you can
make the adjustments the point is that
this is such a simple remedy it's a
no-brainer
for anyone that is either
pre-diabetic or diabetic it's just
something that you should do to see some
great improvement
you can add lemon to it or ginger to
spice it up or even take episode of
vinegar pills now one last point I
highly recommend you do organic outside
of vinegar unfiltered and raw why
because you're going to get just more
microbes when you consume outside of
vinegar that's an organic state the
microbes are more diverse ninety-two
microbes versus conventional outside of
vinegar which is only 72 so you're going
to get some additional benefit for your
digestion all right guys go ahead and
try this and put your comments down
below so if you like this video go ahead
and share it with someone that you know
that can truly benefit from it